meanwhile we've got a lot of violence
going on here in the united states
we got a lot of national disintegration
here in the united states the cop who
killed ashley babbitt the trump
supporter from the capitol
he's speaking out for the first time
so this cop goes on nbc news
this is the cop who killed ashley
babbitt a trump supporter in the capitol
she went into an area she wasn't
supposed to and she gets shot and killed
we were told that the trump supporters
were violent terrible they were killing
cops that just none of that was true
none of that was driven the new york
times in washington post had to admit it
the only person who was killed in the
political violence of that day was
ashley babbitt a trump supporter here is
the cops defense
i followed my training
and i spent
countless years
and
preparing for such a moment you
ultimately hope that moment never occurs
but you prepare as best you can i know
that day i saved countless lives
i know members of congress as well as my
fellow officers and staff were in
jeopardy
and in serious danger
and
that's my job
i don't think he killed countless lives
regardless that he saved countless lives
i don't
i don't know about his claim about his
training and he did what he was supposed
to do and maybe it was a fair shot i
don't know i mean that an investigation
or a trial actually would determine that
but i don't think he saved countless
lives do you know why
because because no one was killed that
day except for ashley babbitt so you're
telling me of all the people that were
in the capital of all the people in all
the places the only one who was supposed
to deadly threat
was ashley babbitt she was going to kill
people
no one else not the horn guy not the
lectern guy not any of the other people
just ashley babbitt and that's why this
unarmed woman was shot to death by this
cop
and no one's asking questions
i'm not i'm not even saying the guy
should go to jail
it is certainly the case that if it was
a white cop killing a black woman
or a pro-trump cop killing a democrat
woman the guy would be in guantanamo bay
the guy would have had his life he would
have been doxxed his we would have heard
from him much sooner than this his
family would be threatened he would
certainly be in jail at least if not
executed
but it's a black cop
defending the democrats killing a trump
supporter so
totally fine there won't there won't be
a thorough investigation of this and
there should be
up up up don't hit that button don't hit
that next video button just wait one
second if you wouldn't mind leave me a
comment say hello say hi michael i'll
say hey there hey buddy what's going on
subscribe ring the bell like it head on
over apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play type in the michael noll
show subscribe leave a five star review
is there anything else i can ask you to
do before we go no i don't think so see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]